hey youtubers it's Charlie so they've
revealed a little bit about what's going
on with spider-man and Captain America's
Civil War so this is gonna be a
breakdown of that as well as an
explainer for a couple of the other
characters like Martin Freeman's Everett
Ross so the big news about spider-man is
that he's not gonna surface until after
battle lines have been drawn team Iron
Man team cap they didn't say which team
he's going to join but they did say he
would form a attachment you
quote-unquote attachment with one
character in particular I think there
are a couple clues that tell us which
team that's going to be and I think it's
gonna be relatively similar to comic
book civil war even though they're not
doing comic book Civil War for the movie
there there are a lot of details that
have been changed but I think a lot of
it has to do with the aged spider-man is
and how impressionable is like the
people that he looks up to and him
getting woke to what's really going on
so think about it this way you have a 15
year old science geek that probably
looks up to Iron Man but then realizes
just because he's team Iron Man doesn't
necessarily make teamcap wrong I kind of
think of the Iron Man character as the
teenage fantasy anyway billionaire
playboy philanthropist all the most
awesome extreme things you could be
Captain America on the other side of
that equation is still a fantasy but
he's more of an adult fantasy like you
grow out of the manchild phase you get a
little more mature that's Captain
America as compared to Iron Man even
though neither one is in the wrong
technically Iron Man does develop a lot
of technology that helps humanity he
does good things it's just that he's
kind of a man-child so you see how a lot
of teenagers might look up to him
automatically even if you're not a
science geek like Peter Parker is Peter
Parker is the prototypical aspiring
science bro also some really cool
evidence that I think he's going to be
team Iron Man the trailer that they just
released for the Super Bowl has Iron Man
putting on one of his gloves to stop the
bullet from Bucky does that not look
like it starts as a wristwatch like he
sticks the wristwatch on in the glove
forms around it isn't that something
that you could turn into a mechanical
web shooter Kevin Feige he's already
revealed that in New York right now
there is a teenage spider-man web
slinging around he's already got his
powers wearing a very low fight teenage
version of the costume a costume that
looks like it was built by a 15 year old
kid so we're talking hoodie here and I
know there was a hoodie that was going
around the internet I actually
pre-ordered it but it's not supposed to
be delivered till this summer I have
absolutely no idea if this is the actual
spider-man costume it might be but I
think that spider-man is wearing a
t---shirt version of the costume
he joins team Ironman gets a slightly
upgraded version then gets whoa okay
whoa we're hunting down someone who
isn't wrong but as for his actual role
in the movie I don't know how pivotal
he's going to be in the fight because
James Gunn made the joke a while ago
that he only has four minutes of screen
play now I don't know if he was just
joking around so I don't want to take
that too seriously
but it sounds like spider-man is
somewhat of a fringe character I think
the Iron Man will play continued role in
spider-man's evolution just like cap
will but it's probably whatever death
ends up happening in the movie that kind
of catalyzes spider-man's view in the
whole situation where he's like okay you
know you guys are really awesome but
somebody just died so this is
and even though iron man's relationship
with Captain America is gonna be a much
bigger thing in the movie thematically
than his relationship with spider-man I
think it's pretty easy to assume that
Tony Stark would think of Peter Parker
is somewhat of a son type figure maybe
not an actual son it's not like he's
gonna adopt him anytime soon but he
might see spider-man as a younger
version of himself and that might help
Iron Man get woke to what's really going
on I realized that the sokovia accords
are a big deal yes we need to bring
Winter Soldier in but it's not worth the
death of my friends I know the whole
idea is kind of silly like how crazy
would Iron Man have to be to be so
stubborn that he would fight his friend
cap in one of their friends would die
like Avengers versus Avengers how nuts
is their thought process that things get
this bad between them that's really what
the job of the first two acts of the
film are I'm guessing that Captain
America in this scene here finds Winter
Soldier in the first act of the film
then they have this a co V Accords iron
man's like we got to bring him in and
that's when things spiral out of control
now there is a whole lot of other stuff
going on too around the movie you have
Everett Ross who's Martin Freeman's
character he is from the comic books
then you have crossbones who seems like
he's trying to destabilize the situation
you have Baron Zemo so let's talk about
some of those other characters but let
me know in the comments do you think
that spider-man is gonna start out team
Iron Man and then go team cap by the end
of the movie or do you think he's always
gonna be team Iron Man or always team
cap it just stands to reason that if
Peter Parker's a science geek he's going
to look up to science Bros he's gonna
get an upgraded version of his costume
and that's gonna come from Iron Man so
he has to start out there no matter
where he ends up at the end of the film
but other characters Everett Ross Martin
Freeman is going to be so much fun in
the
movie he looks like such an and
I am so excited in the comics Everett
Ross is a government liaison for foreign
diplomats so if he's gonna be exactly
like he is in the comics then he's
really gonna be serving Black Panthers
character because he'd be the foreign
diplomat from Wakanda but in the
Christopher priest Black Panther title
there was like a brief Christopher
priest run that's actually pretty badass
if you want to read a Black Panther
story wherever it Ross is assigned to
lead Black Panther around New York and
things spiral out of control he's a
relatively minor character but I'm
guessing based on that that he will be
connected to Black Panthers character in
the movie even if they expand the
context of his role a little bit but
Marvel has revealed that in the movie
he's going to be part of what's called
the joint counter-terrorist Center so
whatever has involved with Black Panther
this anti-terrorist group will play a
big role in the film and they're the
ones that are trying to keep Captain
America and Iron Man accountable the
Avengers accountable and they probably
get the tip on Winter Soldier and want
to go after him
so in Captain America goes against the
government he's probably going against
this counter terrorist group and Ironman
just agrees with what they're doing they
give the counter terrorist group in the
movie as what replaces shield because
Nick Fury isn't supposed to be in the
movie he's kind of blowing in the wind
shield is in ruins
so this international anti-terrorist
unit seems like it fills the void and
because Everett Ross is such a big
character for Black Panther in the
comics I do think that Martin Freeman is
gonna have a big role in the Black
Panther solo film in related comic-book
news though this is a big week for DC TV
King shark tonight on the flash I'll be
posting that video after the episode
airs so be sure to subscribe to get it
Wednesday we're gonna see vixen from the
comics on arrow and then Thursday on
legends of tomorrow we're gonna see
future versions of the characters we'll
see Connor Hawke and a future version of
Deathstroke which I think is gonna wind
up being Joe Wilson the Jericho
character would just look out for those
videos I'll be posting some Marvel stuff
in between all that so why cos wait for
that video to post tonight you can click
here for all my Captain America Civil
War videos and you can click here for my
Batman V Superman Justice League teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you